Ajax stands for asynchronous JavaScript
and XML request we could ignore the XML
part of the acronym for now let's just
think of it as an asynchronous
JavaScript request Ajax requests allow
for content retrieval and display
without reloading the webpage
asynchronous in Ajax refers to the fact
that the request doesn't block other
events from happening instead the page
keeps on doing its thing and then only
acts on the data when it gets returned
by the server Ajax requests occur in a
number of different ways and with
varying levels of difficulty some
require an API key others use OAuth and
some don't use any authentication at all
and the data returned by different Ajax
requests defers to X and Ajax stands for
XML which used to be the dominant
hierarchical data format but today JSON
is much more popular in fact most Ajax
requests nowadays are actually a judge
request standing for asynchronous
JavaScript and JSON requests but it
doesn't sound as nice so still just call
them Ajax embedded within Ajax responses
it's pretty common to see HTML which
websites can use to fill in part of the
page as part of the project for this
course you'll have to try three
different asynchronous request
techniques you'll have to work with the
Google Streetview
Wikipedia and New York Times api's all
three of which work very differently